هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا خلال اولى ساعات
الصباحات انطاكيا المنكوبه فرار جماعي
للناجين من الزلزال الذي جعلها تاي من
اكبر المدن تضررا منهم من يملك وجهه محدده
ومنهم من سيحددها لاحقا خلال ساعات الرحله
الطويله بحثا عن الامان يعني
[موسيقى]
راحوا لله الامر بس
كل جيراني في هذه البنايه والحي غادروا
الى مدن اخرى انا كذلك تقرر هدم بيت
المتصدع وساذهب الى انقره واعيش هناك عند
اقاربه
كما السوريين الذين الفوا الترحاله دخل
الاتراك كذلك في هجره داخليه الى مدن
الشمال وعكسيه اعادت المئات منهم الى
القرى هنا بقريه جلباش بضواحيها تاي
ياملون النجاه بانفسهم من الزلزال وهزاته
المتتاليه لكن هذه السيده لا تامن الوضع
وتفضل الخيمه على البقاء داخل بيتها
منذ حدوث زلزال عدنا الى قران التي اصبحت
مزدحمه هي الاخرى هنا الوضع اقل خطوره من
مركز هاتاي لكني اخاف البقاء في البيت
لذلك انا في الخيمه
اما هذا الرجل فوجد نفسه لاجئا في خيمه
حتى وهو يعود الى قريته التي غادرها قبل
خمسه عقود من الاربعه وسبعين لها اليوم
هذا من القريه بعيد
وهسه
رجعنا على مكان الاول باركين بالخيام مع
الندور ما عندنا شيء وفقا للارقام الرسميه
فقد عاد اكثر من اربعين الف سوري طواعيه
الى سوريا فيما لم يتم الكشف بعد عن اعداد
المنكوبين من الاتراك وغيرهم ممن نزحوا
مدن تركيه اخرى
تطمينات السلطات التركيه باعاده اعمار
المناطق المتضرره سريعا لم توقف موجات
النزوح الى عشرات الالاف من المنكوبين ما
يؤشر الى حدوث تغير ديموغرافي قد يزيد من
متاعب الحكومه في معالجه اثار الزلزال عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه